كره ثلج الازمه الاوكرانيه تكبر يوما بعد
يوم حادث المسيرتين فوق قصر الكرملين صب
الزيت اكثر فوق نيران الحرب المشتعله اصلا
موسكو وبعد اتهامها بمحاوله اغتيال بوتين
صعدت اللهجه اكثر الخارجيه الروسيه توعدت
برد يكون بحجم التهديد سهام الانتقاد
الروسيه اتجهت مباشره نحو الولايات
المتحده فقرارات القيام بمثل هذه الاعمال
تتخذ في واشنطن وليس كيا التي تنفذ يقول
الكرملين
مثل هذه القرارات وتعريف الاهداف وتعريف
الوسائل كل هذا تمليه واشنطن على
اوكرانيا نفت الاتهامات الروسيه جمله
وتفصيلا ووصفتها بالكاذبه فرسيا اختلقت
الهجوم لكونها تعلم انها خسرت الحرب
والكريم لان يستغل هذه الروايه لتحفيز
جنوده على الاستمرار في الحرب ومقدمه لعمل
عسكري شامل وفق كيف اما زيلينس كيف حاول
القيام بهجمه مرتده من داخل مقر محكمه
الجنايه الدوليه عبر المطالبه بمحاكمه
الرئيس الروسي
تجب معاقبه بوتين على افعاله هنا في عاصمه
القانون الدولي حليف اوكرانيا على الاتحاد
الاوروبي دعا الى عدم استخدامه هجوم
الكريم ذريعه لتصعيد الحرب ويكو ندع روسيا
الى عدم استخدام هذا الهجوم المزعوم ذريعه
لمواصله هذا التصعيد للحرب اكبر داعم لكي
اف سياسيا العسكريا الولايات المتحده ابدت
تشكيكها فيما يقع البيت الابيض قال انه
ينظر بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن موسكو في
وقت اشارت الامم المتحده الى انه لا يمكن
تاكيد المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني
على الكرملين بلال البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات